todo está listo para el despegue de la
cápsula cruz dragón con destino a la
estación espacial internacional un
lanzamiento que fue postergado por mal
clima pero que tendrá lugar este viernes
en la mañana a bordo habrá cuatro
astronautas dos de la nasa están hay
cumbre y megan mcarthur también estará
aquí y koksijde de la agencia espacial
japonesa y por parte de la agencia
espacial europea el francés thomas es
que es que que se convertirá en el
primer francés en el primer europeo en
participar en una de estas misiones
comerciales tripuladas entre la nasa y
también space six y además esta misión
también es una de las primeras entre
estas tres agencias que se realizan en
los últimos 20 años crudos como se llama
la misión que tendrán estos cuatro
astronautas tendrán que relevar a cruz
uno que es la tripulación que viajó a la
estación espacial el pasado mes de
noviembre
ahora crudos pues parte estará durante
seis meses a bordo de la estación
espacial allí tendrá que llevar a cabo
un centenar de experimentos científicos
en especial sobre los efectos de la
microgravedad
cuerpo humano como en el proceso de
envejecimiento y parte de estos
experimentos serán pilotados desde aquí
desde la ciudad de toulouse donde está
el centro nacional para la investigación
espacial además de esto tendrán cuatro
salidas al vacío espacial para cambiar
una parte de los paneles solares de la
plataforma especial su dragón se espera
despegue en la mañana de este viernes
desde cabo cañaveral a las 541 de la
mañana hora del este de eeuu y se acople
a la estación espacial internacional en
la mañana del sábado